regime change operation the cia comes
with up with a
assassination list of people that they
are going they are their proxies who are
going to start this this this
regime change operation
was okay to assassinate
amazing
now if we jump ahead some 20 years or so
20 years
1970 to 73
we go to chile which is even further
away from the united
states way they they succeeded and that
regime changed operation they ousted
arbans from power luckily he was able to
get out without being assassinated
so but in chile the chilean people do
the same thing
they have the temerity to democratically
elect and in a long democratic tradition
in this country a self-about socialist
communist uh he was a physician
he was an intellectual
uh his his name was salvador allende and
he made no bones about it and so he wins
a plurality and and the congress is
getting ready to to confirm him as
president and all the alarm bells go off
in washington again uh oh here we are
again another communist democratically
elected this is not good and then
allende makes it even worse because he's
there talking about his you know wants
to establish friendship with the soviet
union he's got nothing against russia
moscow
he later invites fidel castro to to to
chile to visit the country
well that sealed his fate
now
it's allende who's deemed a threat to
national security and so
the order is given
regime change the cia goes in they try
to bribe the members of congress so that
they don't vote for agenda to confirm if
it's president that doesn't work
so there's they start talking about a
coup a military coup to take take
control and prevent allende from coming
into power
but there's one big obstacle
and and that's a man named general renee
schneider
who is the overall commanding general of
of of chile's armed forces
and and schneider a man of impeccable
integrity he's a family he's got a
couple a couple of sons and
he says to
u.s officials it ain't going to happen
i'm a soldier i took an oath to support
and defend the constitution of my
country
it provides only for impeachment
or elections to oust the president from
office it does not provide for a
military coup
into story
well the cia's position was different
they're here telling
the uh
um renee schneider and the rest of the
military intelligence establishment the
national security establishment of this
country
look you have a moral duty to save this
country the country's going down with
allende it's going to go down with
communism it's going to go down with
socialism when he starts adopting all
these programs
and it doesn't matter don't tell us
technicalities of your constitution and
what the law says because if the country
goes down what good's your constitution
you have a moral duty as a national
security establishment to save your
country by violently ousting your
president from office
and taking control and saving the
country
schneider stands his ground
so a conspiracy arises within washington
virginia or both
in which the decision is made
to kidnap
schneider violently and remove him from
the scene
now the cia's always denied that the
conspiracy involved uh murdering him but
they lied about every other aspect of
the cube of the chile operation and the
denials ring false because what else
could they have done they kidnapped the
guy the coup takes over and what are
they going to return him to society
there wasn't any chance of that and in
fact the kidnapping attempt takes place
the the cia smuggles in under diplomatic
pouch two high-powered weapons um
arbin's i mean um uh uh schneider is is
armed he's he's a general and he fights
back against the kidnappers and they
shoot him dead
and so the the obstacles removed and
over a three year period of time the cia
is stirring up things in the country
bribing truckers not to deliver food and
creating all kinds of chaos and crises
along with allende's socialist policies
which not surprisingly were also causing
chaos and crises much as as uh they are
in in venezuela today and so all this
leads to a coup
where uh the the national security
establishment is attacking the president
with missiles from the air force jets
and and infantry surrounding his
position and allende is fighting back
with small arms fire with some some
supporters but
he ends up dead apparently committed
suicide
general pinochet takes power proceeds to
round up
tens of thousands of people kidnapping
them putting him into military dungeons
raping them his forces were
committing the most gruesome sexual acts
against the women that you can even
imagine
disappearing them or or executing them
including two americans with the
complicity of u.s intelligence agents
and the idea was and and the us was
flooding pinochet's regime with with
foreign aid at this point they thought
he was fantastic
that what he was doing to all these
people was wonderful because they were
communists
you see i mean
if they're communists it's no problem
doing this because this is a cold war
now obviously the u.s wasn't doing this
to communists in in america they were
just surveilling them and harassing them
and destroying their careers in chile he
was going all the way he was killing
communists and by the way
communists were still killing u.s troops
in vietnam at this time so it was all
considered war